what do you think about Switzerland what
do you think of you think of mountains
and skiing you think of luxury watches
beautiful chocolate and banking
we're in Switzerland both from a GDP and
economy perspective but also just as a
national identity people are actually
proud of their Banks and a lot of people
work in finance well there's just
historically a lot of expertise here
when it comes to banking particularly
around banking for those who are rich
that went quite well up until it didn't
UBS buying credit Suites this ends a 166
year run for Credit Suisse it was a
historic day and a day we hoped would
not happen UVS now after takeover has
provided stability but it creates a
potentially bigger problem in the future
thank you
[Music]
Swiss banking has built a reputation for
reliability stability and discretion
underpinning those attributes are two
key policies secrecy and neutrality
secrecy was always a really big selling
point for the industry and it's part of
what helps attract so much money and
grow so large
the neutral status of the country made
it in a very reliable place for the rich
people all over the world all things
being equal Swiss banks would not have
been able actually to compete with
Financial Centers such as London or
Paris that were really at the heart of
huge industrial economies but it did
have one Edge the principle of secrecy
that dated back to the early 18th
century so when at the start of the 20th
century other European nations started
increasing their taxes Swiss Bankers
sensed an opportunity
this is an ad published in La rovu
Francaise in 1911 but the cantonal bank
of Bern it says that any deposit made by
a foreigner who is not resident in
Switzerland is actually exempt from
paying all Swiss taxes
plenty of other lenders followed a
similar attack in the years that
followed the two World Wars meant that
Switzerland's neutrality made it an even
more appealing location to deposit your
cash without anyone knowing about it
as Switzerland became more of a player
on the international stage one of the
ways that banking developed was to take
the status of the stability of the
political system and the neutrality of
the country to offer a safe haven for
people
at the heart of it all our Credit Suisse
and UBS two Banks headquartered just a
few hundred yards apart in central
Zurich
by the 1970s global banking had started
to change with increased globalization
came more opportunities but to also
increased competition and scrutiny over
time people started to demand their
higher returns money laundering became
more of an issue in the 80s into the 90s
terrorist financing became a really big
issue in the early 2000s a few major if
historical scandals started not only to
chip away at Switzerland's reputation
around this time but they also drew the
attention of international regulatory
authorities as attention focused on
Switzerland's banking secrecy in the
1980s a new business model had begun to
emerge what if the banks could take the
vast wealth they were tending for their
clients and pair it with an investment
bank that could direct the capital into
exciting New Opportunities like initial
public offerings and deal making
Credit Suisse Sports first Boston and
then later on Donaldson Lufkin and
generet and UBS bought Payne Weber the
combination of payneware brand UBS
is a match made in heaven that went
quite well up until it didn't in about
2007.
Victor bored the brunt of the collapse
with shares in Europe's major Banks
tanking by as much as nine percent major
financial institutions have teetered on
the edge of collapse
and some have failed we've had a
historic day on Wall Street Lehman
Brothers the 158 year old firm filed for
a chapter 11 protection in U.S
bankruptcy court today this is when the
two Banks paths really diverge
UBS finds itself in crisis along with
the Global Financial world and it has to
take a state bailout
it decided one to seriously cut back
pretty much everything it did in the
sort of the bonds trading and two there
was a kind of you know a reset of the
culture it became out of that a much
more humble much reduced Bank while UBS
was forced to change and take fewer
risks Credit Suisse was not in fact it
made things worse risk control has
obviously many many facets right one is
compliance yet at another level for the
Investment Bank it's about knowing your
trading positions right now one thing
they did they fired a lot of people
senior people who were watching out for
risky trading positions and instead they
hired a lot of young people who probably
did this job for the first time and that
later backfired
but at the same time they're still
living on that old reputation for
stability and responsibility
what Swiss banks ended up kind of
selling to investors to their private
clients was this kind of this old idea
of quality and safety and security that
they'd also always kind of traded off of
and when things started to go wrong when
Banks started to lose more money on
behalf of their clients that really
undermines that sort of reputation for
safety and soundness
svb Bank closed closed by the regulator
Xbox Europe 600 then being dragged down
by the financial services sector by the
banking sector down by 2.75 percent
deal done UBS will buy Credit Suisse for
three billion Swiss Francs this is where
the government came in with a Lifeline
of liquidity we were speaking uh very
closely with key Regulators notably or
most importantly the ones in the US and
the UK they were deeply involved and you
have seen today their support for the
solution credit series will no longer be
an independent company at the same time
this means a new beginning and huge
opportunities ahead for the combine bank
and for the Swiss Financial Center as a
whole while UBS might be a more trusted
brand a part of the rescue has some
questioning whether Switzerland itself
is a safe place to invest
this is Switzerland bailing in the
bondholders
[Music]
typically bondholders take precedence
over shareholders that means the people
who loaned the company cash get their
money back before the people that own
the business
what happened with Credit Suisse was
that people who owned the company's
shares received a total of about three
billion dollars far less in the company
had been worth just days earlier but a
class of debts known as additional tier
one bonds was completely wiped out to
the tune of 17 billion dollars they were
asking look um we are losing all our
money now why would we give you money in
the future and that was another big
problem of this merger because
it will make financing for Swiss banks
when they want to lend more expensive
going forward
Brokers maintained that this was the
best of a bunch of bad Solutions
there's another reason why the new UBS
Mega Bank could be problematic for a
small country like Switzerland the Swiss
state is hoping that by merging these
two companies you get a bit of The Best
of Both Worlds so you get the expertise
that's been developed at credit Suites
and perhaps some of that more Innovative
stuff but then also the stability and
this sort of stoic culture that UBS has
UBS now after takeover has provided
stability straight away but it creates a
potentially bigger problem in the future
ubs's balance sheet is now twice the
size of this Swiss economy that's
obviously massive and it begs the
question if UBS wherever to run into
trouble could Switzerland afford to bail
them out
in the last financial crisis we talked
about Banks being too big to fail
meaning governments had to bail them out
the new expanded UBS represents a
different risk that the Swiss government
just doesn't have enough money to bail
it out
[Music]
foreign